hi I'm Tom mcshay i finished dark souls
and here's Kevin van dort he reviewed
dark souls we're here to talk about Dark
Souls 2 because we both played dark
souls 2 so you just went to an AAMCO
event right i went to namco bandai wet
what was it what did you play I had to
buy first hour of the game well ok I
didn't actually play an hour into the
game but I played for an hour from the
very beginning of the game so I had the
story set up and I had ok you have to
name your character I had all of that
good this is an RPG and I skipped all of
that stuff because I don't want to know
what it is really yes but you did play
you had a high-character you only got
into the cop and I yeah and I walked
around the world and explored it and
it's it's as gorgeous and haunting as
you would expect and of course I played
a little bit of the the closed beta yep
and unfortunately the second closed beta
weekend didn't work here in the United
States you played like a random I did
play third of the way a portion that
they give you yeah whatever portion that
is and it was it was super interesting
because it was dark souls it was clearly
dark souls here is dark souls and
they're going to put a two on the end of
it and see how that goes so one of the
differences that stood out for me is
puzzles and I don't know how much
puzzles actually play a part because it
only seemed like it but there was the
game there was unlit torches and I got a
torch from somewhere far away that's
stayed lit for five minutes I ran back
to light torches and I couldn't get them
all but that seems like something we
hadn't seen in dark or demon souls
before is that kind of element there's
also a door I needed open and there's a
statue in front of the lock so I have to
find a way to move that statue out of
the way and it could be an interesting
change of pace if like in addition to
figure out where to go I have to figure
out how it gets there right a little
tumor a Turing if you have all may also
i mean it draws unsettled us so much and
this is kind of going like Link to the
Past style where there's actually
puzzles in addition to the dungeon right
because before you have to just really
just complete areas to get to the point
where you could open that door or beat
the boss that allows you to gain access
an area but this is this is a little bit
different if that's the case if and
maybe that's in the sense how they're
talking about it being open no yeah you
don't have you're not going to have to
beat a boss behind a wall of fog in
order to gain access maybe it's just
solving puzzles and being good enough to
actually get there and do it so even if
this is like ninety percent dark souls
is that a bad thing no not necessarily I
mean it and this has actually been a
little bit of a concern of mine it's
like because Dark Souls it's your
favorite game of all time it's my
favorite game at least of the generation
i have to say of all time but certainly
of the generation and so you know more
Dark Souls isn't a bad thing for people
that love dark souls but on the other
hand can you recreate magic when you're
just doing the same thing in a new
setting and that's that's what I'm
curious about is it going to retain the
magic because Dark Souls even though it
felt like demon souls still was very
much its own probably change the system
was very different yeah and the health
system is a little different this time
too as far as I can tell fifth week
there are some tweaks but I guess I
guess the thing is like we don't have an
answer to is this more dark souls yet
right Italy is but it's not gonna be any
more than darcel and then yeah the
people you know through previews week we
don't know yet that sounds like we're
just gonna live you leave you with like
a big question mark yeah is this more
dark souls in a good sense or is this
more dark souls in a bin there done that
I'm putting an exclamation point on it
and it's coming up March 11th and I'm
going to be playing it not so all day
long
you